when russia's war hit this small village
outside kiev it took the heart out of a
single road
p street
two young men grew up together here a
few houses apart
victor ballet in the yellow t-shirt
pavel koladenko in the white
now two shattered families are all
that's left
they say russian soldiers captured
tortured and shot the childhood friends
their broken bodies found buried
together in a shallow grave
the local priest the only comfort
push
foreign
she clung to the memory of her only
child
victor and pavel both used to serve in
the military it's probably why they were
murdered she last spoke to her son in
late february when russian tanks rolled
into the village
the two friends had been planning to
volunteer to fight again
much
as we spoke pavel's mother appeared
she showed us their house
and her raw paintings
[Music]
and do you believe that um your son and
his friend were
captured and tortured and killed
together
photographs of pavel remembered fondly
he and victor were only 28 years old
no one knows what day they died
their remains only found after russian
forces withdrew
the priest helped give them a proper
burial
he showed us pavel's final resting place
a permanent reminder of what russia's
war did to the two young friends from
peace street
debra haynes sky news zed
outside kiev